[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la chanson qu'on vient de vous jouer je
ne l'avais jamais encore chanté en
public
c'est
[Applaudissements]
je l'écris il y a peu de temps pour
l'album que nous préparons ensemble avec
mon groupe lighline The koalas
habituellement avec moi sur scène il y a
Paul qui est comme un frère avec qui je
joue depuis presque 15 ans mais
aujourd'hui il ne pouvait pas être là
ensemble depuis un an et demi on écrit
nouvelle chanson et ce sont ses chansons
que je vous chante aujourd'hui grâce à
la présence d'une femme lumineuse qui
s'appelle comme naan
[Applaudissements]
cette chanson elle s'appelle
elle parle de nos crises et de l'amour
qui guérit
en temps de crise je ressens cette
urgence à faire sortir les émotions qui
me traversent aller droit au but à
transformer toutes ces questions que je
me pose pour construire quelque chose de
nouveau une chanson
on connaît tous la peine de l'insécurité
de l'incertitude de la vie
et depuis toute petite face à cette
peine j'ai la même intuition ces
chantées je me dis là maintenant tout de
suite il faut que je chante
si je ne chante pas je pourrais
m'effondrer
je crois en la nécessité d'exprimer les
émotions qu'on ressent sinon elle
revienne nous rendre visite nous ronger
nous abîmer de l'intérieur
je crois que le silence ne guérit rien
et qu'il faut se parler et pour moi
le plus instinctif c'est de parler en
chantant
quand je chante une chanson je me sens
reliée relié à mes émotions mais surtout
relié à celles et ceux qui m'écoutent et
à ce qui nous réunit et dans ce monde où
on cherche sans cesse des oppositions
des contradictions où on confronte les
identités les communautés moi je crois
tellement plus fort en ce qui nous
réunit
j'ai grandi dans la campagne bretonne
dans une ancienne ferme que mes parents
rénovaient
mon père il était arrivé d'Afrique à
l'âge de 14 ans tout seul pour
travailler dans les usines
mon père il est musulman et ma mère elle
vient d'une famille catholique bretonne
alors dans notre maison à Noël on se
réunissait autour de la crèche et on
chantait ensemble les cantiques mes
nuits chrétiens les anges dans nos
campagnes tout y passer et au Nouvel An
mon père il sortait les percussions
traditionnelles et on se mettait à
chanter à danser en imaginant des
chansons attache sa langue sa langue
maternelle
personne ne savait parler cette langue à
part lui donc on imaginait
on imaginait on crée et dans ces
moments-là je me sentais tellement relié
à mes parents
j'étais une enfant super timide et grâce
à la musique je me connectais à mes
frères on avait notamment une cassette
de Bob Marley
et on la mettait comme ça
en silence on écoutait dans notre
chambre avec nos lits superposés
enchanté
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que je trouvais ma place
dans cette famille et dans ce monde
j'avais 9 ans le jour où je suis arrivée
dans les contreforts des montagnes de
l'Atlas rencontrer la terre de mon père
cette rencontre elle a été compliquée
pour un enfant qui parle pas la langue
de sa famille
et celles qui m'ont ouvert les portes à
ce moment là ce sont les Spice Girls
en fait toutes mes cousines
connaissaient leurs chansons et donc on
s'installait sur la terre battue de la
Casbah à notre droite il y avait les
moutons qui balaient à notre gauche il y
avait le four dans lequel et on chantait
alors aucune d'entre nous ne connaissait
les paroles on faisait un yaourt absolu
mais à ce moment-là
les chansons des Spice Girls c'était le
langage qui pouvait nous réunir
et encore aujourd'hui l'odeur mélangée
des crottes de mouton sèches à celles du
pain qui cuit dans le four je pense que
c'est une de mes odeurs préférées
plus tard tous nos étés il se passaient
sous ce soleil brûlant du village
et l'espace Girls ont laissé leur place
j'ai commencé à écouter d'autres
mélodies c'était mes tantes mais tant
elle chantait en faisant la cuisine en
allant au mariage en allant laver le
linge à l'eau de la rivière elle
chantait des mélodies ancestrales
transmises de femmes en femmes de
génération en génération je comprenais
pas leur mot mais les mélodies aiment
parler
[Musique]
j'adorais cette chanson je savais pas ce
que ça voulait dire et j'ai compris plus
tard que mes temps elles chantaient
dis-lui dis-lui dis-lui que puis-je bien
faire de cette vie
alors j'ai grandi bercé par toutes ces
mélodies et arriver à l'adolescence j'ai
été traversée d'une crise
celle d'être un mélange que les gens
voulaient reconnaître définir étiqueter
et moi je me reconnaissais dans aucune
de ces étiquettes alors je me cherchais
je me suis lisser les cheveux il faut
imaginer
je vous laisse changer de prénom
je cherchais à entrer dans une case
alors que personne ne peut rentrer dans
une case
mais c'est grâce à cette crise que j'ai
commencé à écrire mes premières chansons
et depuis j'écris toujours en temps de
crise
c'est comme une thérapie je m'installe
dans le silence dans la solitude
et je chante des mélodies qui viennent
d'une certaine manière me cicatriser
avant que la musique ne devienne mon
métier j'étais professeur d'histoire
ça n'a pas duré longtemps un mois et
demi
mais
j'ai voulu j'ai voulu tout laisser tout
quitter et je suis parti
avec une amie on est parti aux
États-Unis on a acheté les billets de
car les moins chers possibles c'était
les bus greyound et on est parti comme
ça on a traversé l'est du pays de Boston
anashville avec nos sacs sur le dos pour
un long voyage et là encore pour ce
voyage et pour tous les autres qui ont
suivi ensuite quand j'y suis retournée
avec des amis musiciens c'était la
musique c'était les chansons qui me
faisait entrer en contact
je me souviens d'un soir où on se
perdait dans une ville de Caroline du
Sud à Charleston
on arrive dans une gare routière à
moitié vide
sauf deux hommes installé sur un banc
en nous entendant parler français l'un
d'entre eux nous appelle et je m'appelle
youjin et je sais parler français je
sais parler français je sais dire une
phrase en français
alors on s'approche
écoutez cette phrase il nous dit j'ai
mal à la tête à cause du bruit
j'ai pas compris mais en voyant la
guitare sur le dos d'un de mes amis il
nous demande à ce que vous connaissez
lean on me de Bill Withers
[Musique]
se souvenir je l'ai remporté avec moi et
tant d'autres souvenirs tu me disais que
la musique que les chansons elles
traversent toutes les barrières de
langue et de culture et revenu en France
j'ai écrit plein de chansons et j'ai
envie de vous chanter un petit bout
d'une de cette chanson alors elle
s'appelle
du fait d'avoir tout déjà en soi
si vous voulez chanter avec moi
faites-vous plaisir je sais que la
plupart d'entre vous ne connaîtront ni
les paroles ni la mélodie mais vous
pouvez chanter en yaourt
[Musique]
j'ai pas renseigné l'histoire très
longtemps
mais ce que j'en ai retenu c'est que en
temps de crise
ce qui nous menace c'est la division
elle vient comme ça dans nos vies dans
nos familles
dans nos relations dans nos sociétés
et pourtant la crise elle est pas là
pour rien c'est un moyen de s'adapter
à ce monde qui change peut-être qu'elle
vient nous chanter elle aussi une
chanson à l'oreille une chanson qui
parlerait de reconstruction
peut-être qu'elle vient nous demander de
repenser notre manière d'être au monde
je crois qu'en chantant en écoutant des
chansons on est mieux accompagné pour
traverser toutes ces tempêtes et moi
là-dedans ce que je veux c'est chanter
les mots de l'amour et du pardon
je crois que ces mots ils sont
universels
et qui permettent de saisir du pouvoir
guérisseur de la musique
alors pour vous dire au revoir je vais
vous chanter une dernière chanson elle
s'appelle de pardon et elle parle
justement de cette cadence sociable de
l'amour et du pardon
aujourd'hui ça sera aussi la première
fois que j'ai la chambre devant un
public et elle sera sur cet album qu'on
prépare avec Leila the kualase je vous
remercie mille fois de m'avoir confié un
peu de votre temps précieux merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]